what's super awesome is like when you're
putting the wins on the board nobody
even gives nobody wants to touch it then
keep going keep going nobody wants to
talk to me
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put
that was pretty uh
that was intense 45 minutes dude
sometimes you have high hopes for a
guest
and i in on this podcast i've been
disappointed today was not that day my
friend i loved that i had a great time
honestly we didn't even get to a we got
to like 20 of the stuff i wanted to ask
him about so we had gary vaynerchuk on
the pod today
it was phenomenal whenever i leave so
i've i've hung out with gary maybe three
or four times maybe three times whenever
i leave his presence i do feel better
and
a lot of people and i'll admit i was one
of those people years ago i would be
like oh this guy's just some loud guy
who's selling nonsense
she's totally the real deal and i went
to we talked about it but i went to a
dinner with him one time and he talked
the entire time
and
most people would be like dude what the
hell that was so rude
and when i left i was like i just want
to continue listening to him i want him
to continue telling stories i love his
point of view he's entertaining
that guy is intense i love it
he does what we try to do
he's been doing it for a long time which
is business entertainment
it's the entertainment side of business
where he you know he'll go to a garage
he'll make content that's like going to
a garage sale buying things for a
quarter and flipping them for 28 on ebay
and how that stacks up and how you can
go from like you know 42 dollars to 14
000 in a year if you just did this and
like obviously he doesn't need to do
that anymore he's got this agency with
you know hundreds of employees he's got
uh you know he's got a bunch of stuff
going on as far as his own business goes
but
i like that
he's been able to do what what i think
the world needs more of it needs more
business entertainment because
like why do i why did i grow up wanted
to be a basketball player because the
nba was so goddamn entertaining right
and and so when you have entertainment
it's that creates inspiration and
aspiration so it ends up creating more
founders in the world
yeah he was amazing man um
whenever i talk about
whenever i'm off with it whenever i'm
with him off the air by the way he's
exactly the same so there's not a
there's no show here so
all right we started off we got right
into it in the first 30 seconds i asked
him so i had been tracking this for a
long time when i was managing my
business i was trying to manage cash
flow and i was trying to understand how
hard to push it and i made a document
from gary vaynerchuk about vaynermedia
they grew to 1200 employees i tracked
the revenue revenue per head over
hundreds of interviews i basically found
where he said a clip like oh we have
this many employees and i asked him
about it so i asked him how he managed
cash flow then we got into a really
interesting discussion about nfts nfts a
lot of people talk about him i'm not
like an nft guy sean you are this was
the one time i've ever had a
conversation where it interested me
beyond just like
academic right yeah he does a good job
with making it i don't know like
uh tangible and like not making the big
mistake which is nfts let me tell you
what it stands for and how it works
under the hood it's like no no i don't
care how the engine works i want to get
in the car and go somewhere so where
does this let me go and i think he did a
pretty good job of that so we talked
about nfts uh we talked about um
you know just somebody kind of like the
lessons learned you know going from like
what he saw in the dot-com boom because
he was kind of like early in the game
right in 2000 and then he was there for
like twitter facebook uber
and he got in he invested in twitter but
he missed out on uber even though
garrett was one of his best friends and
then what he so how did he take that
learning what's he doing now with it
today how does he take those learnings
and apply them now so we talked about
that for a bit but good episode he he
you know he was i don't know super nice
guy uh wants to come back on i think we
should have him on again for sure i take
a lot it makes me feel happy that
sometimes a lot of times people tweet at
us and they say i want to run through a
wall after that episode or i want to go
and accomplish something i feel that way
right now
uh after listening to that episode i
felt like i was a part of it more so uh
as a fan more so as a participant i
thought it was wonderful
yeah you know it's when people say uh
you know i'm always late to work because
when i'm driving listen to mfm i gotta
pull over and write [__] down right like
i can't let this idea go i gotta write
this down that's uh that's when we do it
well and sometimes we don't always hit
that but i think we did it well on this
one so all right that's the episode
garyvee enjoy
like all right are you weird or are you
normal and they're like we're a little
bit of both and then they came out and
did it and it it uh it worked out well
i'm just using an iphone
get the [__] out of here well we're
traveling now sam you looking are you
really
i'm in new york this is just an iphone
oh blurred out why does it look so good
so he got this app that basically uses
your iphone as like a dslr which is
really cool awesome it's nice to see you
guys i hope you're well it's called camo
i'll give them a shout out it's called
camo i think i paid 49 for it it's
awesome man hope everyone's well
um so we have uh a lot to get into um
i'm pumped you're here um can i it's
something that i've and we're recording
now something i've always wondered about
how many people work at vaynermedia
right now
somewhere between
probably 10 50 and 1300.
i'm sorry vaynerx so vaynermedia is the
biggest company yeah vayner right
because we have gallery we have yep
so i was looking uh i did some research
based off a ton of interviews and i was
like going through the head count of how
how fast you grew and i believe between
around years number um
number three and four did you grow from
like 30 people to 125 people
yes because in 2011 september of 2011
i kind of made the decision to go
full-time vayner no longer
what i would call full-time wine library
secondary veiner i made that switch
and then the lighter fluid kind of went
on dude how the hell do you manage that
cash flow for a company like that
because
i i did i did research
and it was tell me if i i just
guesstimated off some interviews
around i'm gonna start at year one
around five people 20 people 30 people
125 people 300 550 600 800. yeah is that
a ballpark right yeah like if i if you
were asking me and i was spitballing
because who the [__] you know the first
year was like
we started in may of 2009 so that that
first half year i think it was like six
or seven
then it might have been like 20 and
through all of 2010 and then until 11 it
probably got to like 30 and then that's
september 2011. look what you'll
appreciate this and you've got this in
you there's certain people who i think
are really really good at top line
revenue driving initiatives
what i think has been the balance of my
life and it's very similar to what
happened at wine library right is
because i'm able to create so much top
line rev
and because i'm playing forever right
wine library my dad's family business
and vayner for me is really for in a
forever business
um
i'm just able to hire a lot
right and then you just gotta you know
with retail it was really easy right i
was like i knew how to sell wine so like
i was with
with b2b it took me a little while to
calibrate like oh [__] they didn't pay
us wait a minute why
the bills do like why didn't you pay but
like overall
um
it's just
staying in your [__] right i think when
you stay in your business and you know
what you've got coming in and what is
going out
you know i'm not a cfo
like oriented ceo
but i'm also not a schlemiel i always
have a good sense of like is this are we
gonna be dead i'm always playing to like
will this hurt me like will i be in
trouble you know i try to stay within
those confines that's it's just crazy i
mean did you have a line of credit from
the bank
no we didn't have a line it's a [__]
wine live this is where my dad's a
[__] psycho i was so undereducated
because i was such a poor student and i
was such a sorry for this background
noise i'll go away in a second um
it was
i my dad
ran his [__] business with no line of
credit which i love right it's old
school immigrant you know pay with what
you have
but it trained me because that business
is even crazier that business went from
four million
to [__]
25 in like 30 months like so fast and
inventory and payroll like but i got so
trained in playing within myself we
didn't have a line of credit for a long
time we definitely got a line of credit
probably 2011 maybe in 2013 so but the
first four or five years and then in the
pocket you're talking about which is
very much more um will resonate a lot
more with people on the call who've got
it who are going to go through the 7 to
17 to 77 to 277
it was more about um
just not spending what you don't have
right like like it was just as simple as
basic being a businessman like hey we
just landed this account they're paying
us 480 a year it's [__] you know
mondelez or pepsi you feel like they're
gonna pay you you feel good it's not
gonna you know and it's like okay now i
got 480. i'm gonna hire these six people
at 40k a piece i feel good with you know
it was like very like
back of the napkin
what's funny about it is
and you know this and i think this is
where you know as when you're on the
podcast we hung out at outdoor dinner
like every time i come there's something
about just like street business
versus like i find myself laughing that
like mine can be like intuitive and back
of napkin and yet people that are like
all about learning and excel sheets and
doing it proper and [__] sap and
cloud you know they have all the
software like get [__] up it's because
they don't have a
good pulse of their actual business so
they get ahead of themselves and lack
patience
yeah it's just like when you're growing
that fast it it seems like like you're
kind of playing it maybe month by month
maybe quarter by quarter where i would
be
i mean just
i would go to bed at night wondering
like
i hope this client doesn't bail
otherwise i gotta lay off yeah 20 people
i think i think what was happening was
we were selling so this and i think i
you know it's so funny i was very
long-winded i think i had the answer
when you are selling at a level that
people are not accustomed to
like when you're outpacing normality
it just [__] selling hides everything
you know when i'm landing [__] client
week after week like you know you start
getting into a place where you're just
outpacing vulnerability
that's always a question i had sean do
you want to give them um
an update on i mean i jumped right into
that because i've always had that
question about man sam's been like
sitting on that question for two years
or something
he didn't say hello he didn't say what
the podcast is [__] about he's like
you know what hey when you scaled how
did you manage cash yeah you know what's
funny i've gotten to know sam through my
podcast in a little couple hangouts uh
it makes sense to me because i think
sam's really good at what he does and
he's and he lived that life and he knows
he did it super well and he knows what
the anxiety and like the challenges are
like it you could you know i always say
you can only
my favorite people to talk to are the
people that know
like i love talking to people that know
because they've lived it not because
they read it it just makes it so much
more fun it's the same way i feel like
when i talk like i love sports but i
fully know when i'm talking to an
athlete i don't know
right i don't know what you know yeah i
did this uh this thread that went viral
on twitter it was about clubhouse and i
was like you know
this is when clubhouse is sort of
peaking and i said this thing i was like
it's kind of unpopular because you know
why [__] on a startup you know it was it
wasn't my intention but i said everybody
thinks clubhouse is the next big thing
and i think it's going to fail but
here's how i think it's going to go play
it out and i kind of wrote it like an
episode of silicon valley like i wrote
it like a like you're the ceo first you
know chris sack is texting you this is
happening and i wrote this thing and it
went viral ended up getting on cnbc it
has like i don't know
tens of millions of impressions
and people were like oh man you're a
good writer
and i was like i'm not a good writer i
[__] i built this thing called blab
that was very similar to clubhouse and i
went through this run and i was getting
all this [__] it wasn't anywhere near
clubhouse but i yeah you know their home
was higher i remember yeah and so i was
like you know i i went through this
exact pain and so i'm just literally
telling a story i know of myself and i'm
exaggerating a little bit to make it
funny it has nothing to do with writing
you know what's so crazy about that i
don't know if you can see this do you
see the goosebumps
it's kind of how i think why i'm a good
content producer i
literally stay in my [__] lane i may
say the same [__] 8 700 different ways
and that's a little bit of my talent i'm
good in incorporating contemporary pop
culture
slang
nuances of the day
but the reason i think it works for me
is similar to you like like i have so
much conviction in my [__] because i'm
not guessing out here right
yeah you know i was watching your uh
trash talk video on the way here so if
you people haven't seen it go to his
youtube fun series actually i was
watching i was like i bet this hits i
couldn't see because i was driving so
i'm listening to it and i'm like god
this is good content i was like i bet
this video hits and of course the views
were pretty high on it
for me and you two i'm starting to
interrupt it's by far my best show it's
my best content
immediately i was like i'm hooked and do
you know why i made it
because i listen to my audience i read
my comments i read my [__] so what was
super awesome was i started getting a
lot of emails from people saying yo
you're awesome i love you but like this
whole like yeah you put a twenty five
thousand dollar check into twitter
they're like that doesn't work for me i
don't have twenty five thousand i'm like
you know cool let me go even further
back in my origin story what did i do
when i dig [__] i [__] fl went garage
sailing on saturday and sold that [__]
at baseball card shows or other flea
markets on
um on sunday right
wait like by the way it's more fun so i
i just sold 3 500 worth of old computers
and i got more joy having that 35
hundred dollars in my venmo than i did
20 million dollars in my face
this brother is everything that i
believe i believe the reason i like
stuff it's easier is i'm in it for the
game i'm just like you i could
there's no comparison to how i feel when
i uh in my last episode and if that's
what you're watching i found
a bunch of magna that's challenging
right so for 270
i bought what ends up being about 6 400
in ebay post fees
sales right it's crazy because it's like
the thrill of the hunt like it was fun
even before that right so i watched my
drive home from the bank to get to home
i didn't get to that part yet but i saw
that was the title
so the the you know some people are like
oh that's cool you buy something for 270
you sell it for six grand the part that
i was blown away by was
the part i was watching you went to 20
[__] garage sales in a day
and i was just thinking to myself two
things i was like
he made the most kind of like this this
channel this show is basically the most
approachable version of entrepreneurship
like yes we we do these segments on the
show that people love that's called uh
we'll do the billy of the week which is
like a billionaire that we profile but
sometimes we'll do the hillbilly of the
week which is someone who owns 22
vending machines and we break down how
much money they make that's [__] so
smart another one we do is called the
blue collar side hustle it's like here's
something you don't need to be a genius
for because sometimes i go off on my
crypto [__] and i'll be like oh yeah
this is the future but then sometimes
it's like hey you know what you should
do like go door-to-door
pest control leads you know
i love billy that's so [__] smart by
the way that's what i'm living right now
i'm like
can't function
because i literally like looked at my
calendar today and i saw we i had this
podcast and obviously you guys have done
a great job and i'm like fired up about
it but like literally in the back of my
brain i'm like man i hope they got
caught up or something because if i get
back that 45 minutes i can go more on
openc and do a little more research i'm
so enthralled right now in nft life that
i'm like every meeting i'm like cutting
five minutes short to like like i'm just
but meanwhile
equally the only other thing that's got
me juiced is garage sale education
because i know it can help people and i
love it it's the same game
do you know um do you know american
pickers
i know that show yes so i used to work
on that show i used to work for mike
wolfe the main guy in that show
who is that the taller guy or the chubby
tall guy the tall guy and the way it
worked is he would go from garage sale
to garage sale not garage sale barnes
and he would buy stuff and we would buy
like some cheap stuff like something we
could sell in the store for 50 bucks
then we would buy some like an old
motorcycle that doesn't work but it's
our we could sell for 20 grand and all
these people would come in from all over
the country to the store that i helped
to run and we would probably sell five
thousand dollars worth of items but we
would sell probably 30 grand a day of
t-shirts
and this freaking business crushed it
but um sean you want to talk about some
nft stuff because so i know that excites
both you it excites me too
are you trying to get into it sam are
you like digging in a little no i i am
i'm into it sean told me what it was
like a year ago and he bought like some
really cool kobe stuff and i went and
got a i thought it was badass and so but
sean's like really into it i think he's
got a ticker behind him that you could
see
yeah no this is this is just you know my
own little i motivate myself with my
motivational quote every day or whatever
but
i do have this programmed up where it
can tell me the price of whatever you
know ethereum or you know uh whether
it's some altcoin or in this case i
start i met the founder of nifty gateway
and i was like dude uh first this story
is hilarious i don't know if you've met
them but it's two twins
um tyler
no so they got there it's two twins that
built nifty gateways they got a fireball
that's [__] amazing and so this was
like pretty early in the wave of like
nft started getting hotter and hotter
and what they did which was smart was
they said look
nfts have value because they're scarce
but the problem is anyone can make a
print an nft tomorrow which is like the
fun but also there's like an abundance
of scarce objects now right supply and
demand
like there's such an incredibly
fascinating supply and demand game going
on what nifty started doing was they
were kind of like look what we'll do is
we'll be like christie's we'll curate so
we'll find the best artists on instagram
and we'll bring them on and they've been
building up this you know people did
their thing i think through through
nifty early on they've been building up
a following for 10 years just doing free
art for the love of the game on
instagram and now that there's a way to
monetize that audience monetize that art
they can bring it over here and so i
bought this like kobe you know the
forever mamba i don't know if you've
ever seen it but basically i was telling
sam on the pod i was like yeah i just
bought this thing for 800 and you know
he goes through the cycle everybody goes
through which is you bought a file like
why are you buying jpegs like what's
that gonna do you spent eight hundred
dollars on this and i was like yeah
actually i bought five he's like you
bought five copies of the same [__]
thing
and you know those sell for 10 10 to 25
okay now and so
um that was my first flip basically my
version of the and the digital garage
sale right that's why i'm so addicted i
think like i'm gonna get i'm addicted to
the digital garage sale and so give us
like your
simplified version of the thesis because
some people kind of like some people
love this [__] they're in the weeds some
people just sit there and eye roll and
then the truth is that there's something
really exciting going on and then
there's also a bunch of [__] that's
going to go away in a few years like
it'll all get swept around so i mean
give us your take yeah i've been you
know i'll just well i'll give you the
micro thing on that i think 98 of the
current projects go to zero right like i
think it's very it's it to me it's this
most similar thing to uh
web internet stocks 99 2000 that i
remember i remember being there i really
like i was me young so i wasn't as
experienced and didn't have as many
pattern recognitions and reps but i had
a lot of the good ingredients right and
i remember sitting there
and saying
man a lot of these businesses make no
sense like just no sense of like how
could they be worth this much money
they're losing so much money and i and i
didn't understand wall street so i
wasn't sure but when the affirmation of
march and april 2000 came along and most
things got smoked out
it kind of was a monumental moment for
me because the only stock that i bought
was amazon
and
and and because i really thought it was
like a real business even though he was
losing money was losing money in a
different way than other things it had
an actual business like back to wow and
i started like revenue mattered like the
other ones didn't have [__] revenue
right you know like no customer gave a
[__] and i'm always like does the
customer care
so
what do i think overall i think people
are grossly underestimating nfts i think
right now people think of them as
collectible in art and flip game and for
a lot of us that have that american
picker garage sale sports cards for me
like and there's a ton of people that
love that like that's that's why half of
wall street
that's where they go like there's a lot
of those people and that's amazing and
that's big that's a big industry like
over the next 15 years big collecting
flipping you know you've got an entire
generation of kids that go on fortnite
and madden and 2k and buy digital assets
to flex so that's going to [__] play
out
but i think that's just a nuance of nfts
i think people misunderstand the utility
nature of smart contracts i believe in
the next 15 years that that nobody
writes a book with a publisher they do
it through an nft infrastructure i
believe that in 15 years nobody launches
a record label by having a a record
record by having a record label give
them the bag they're going to get it
from crowd funding by selling nfts and
giving a percentage of royalties i
believe that there's not a single
sporting event or concert in 10 years
that the ticket is not an nft because
there's no incentive for that
organization and that artist or people
to launch it as anything but an nft
because a qr code or a piece of paper
means nothing but the nft if lukadonic
drops 100 points in that game that
becomes a forever collectible there's a
trillion [__] dollars worth of of
ticket stubs that have sold over the
last 25 years on ebay you know that all
goes to royalties to the person so
what's really fascinating to me uh i'll
give you a weird one if you own a home
that is wildly unique
and is a 25 million home on a beach or
something wild right you nft that
[__] home right now put into the
smart contract that you get one percent
of every transaction of this home in
perpetuity and the first person that's
gonna buy it from you is gonna be fine
with that they don't give a [__] because
these things are long leads right you
buy it you sit on it for 13 15 years so
like there's so much that nft blockchain
realities are going to bring that i
think people are underestimating it
you want to you want to yeah yeah hedge
fund i'll tell them this idea we have
great minds
two months ago a few months ago we're
shooting [__] before an episode and we
don't tell each other what we're going
to talk about it's like yo i'm bringing
three awesome i'm bringing three pieces
of heat you're going to react to it i
got to know my [__] you have to be able
to react and that people like that
people like the reaction
the worst part of a podcast is hey do
you know this yes
okay well let me explain it because i'm
not actually asking you [__]
investing in the audience right i'm
trying to present this here so one of
the ideas that i brought on
was that i noticed that michael jordan's
house had been sitting on the market has
sat on the market at his house in
chicago that's got the 23 emblem on the
gate
it's got like a basketball court inside
got everything
and uh it's been sitting on the market
for years and the price has been
dropping i think i don't know what it
started at i think something like 20
million and then it went down to 15 14
and it's like
so i came on the pot i was like dude i
think we could buy michael jordan's
house for 10 million dollars wow and i
was like you know so we could kind of
like do the you know the way that no but
normally somebody would do this is all
right do i have that kind of fu money to
go buy michael jordan's house my wife
doesn't kill me or do i go you know like
raise a fund amongst you know a few back
alley conversations at dinners with some
folks who are rich i said or we could
just get this podcast we could crowdfund
10 million dollars yep assume and we
could basically fractional we could do
fractions either through an nft or on
rally road or whatever
i was like let's buy michael jordan's
house and we started and this went viral
a little bit in our world like
in my head you listen to every episode
religiously it's your phone
you say cancel you know clear my
calendar i need to go listen to this i
know you probably didn't but that was an
idea we had a few months ago so how
would that play out in the nft world so
walk us through that
you guys and now it sounds like it went
viral and you're like that's exactly
what should happen like i think that's
you can't imagine and i'm a man who
tends to like i don't love that many
ideas right really i mean that i love
execution i think a lot of people can
execute a b and c idea and do great
but to say i love an idea is rare and
that's why i think i've done really well
like i really bet when i love something
and it's worked for me
and i've lost sometimes because the
executor couldn't do it yo bongo was my
favorite investment
it was a precursor to tinder in a lot of
ways caleb and the team there just
couldn't get it there they didn't
execute which is okay
but but when i tell you i love the idea
of buying michael jordan's house
so much because i know
that
you can literally arbitrage it in
perpetuity like i
you guys are people that can garner
attention and promote so it's worth so
much more to you than somebody else i
could see the entire entrepreneurial
ecosystem renting out the basketball
court game like like you can run a real
business now now back to my big point
about unique property i think this is
going to change the real estate industry
the fact that you could put you guys are
young dudes you put a two percent
royalty in perpetuity on that home you
sell it to the next person for nine
million let alone 12 million right let's
just play
you guys are locked your
great-grandchildren
great-great-great-grandchildren are like
our [__]
great-great-great-great-grandfathers
were [__] geniuses we just got a
[__] eight hundred thousand dollar
check in the mail or eighty thousand
whatever it ends up being
i do think in the next five years there
will be a aha
to what nft blockchain smart contracts
mean and i think it will trickle into
real estate people will buy unique
properties
and i think they're gonna make
incredible in perpetuity monies that
maybe they themselves won't get the
crazy because you know how often their
houses turn per se
but man listen
if you're listening to this right now
listen
i've got a real good sense to who
listens to this because you guys got a
lot of fans
you are either there or you are spying
to be there from a professional
standpoint right for the people that are
listening right now who've been
fortunate and we're sitting in this
weird moment right now because of crypto
and nft where there's some people that
have really come into some real money in
like on making a very smart play if
you're sitting with some money you know
these are the things you're thinking
about like what can i do that like is
fun for me
but also leaves for my generational
wealth
i want to do [__] that still is good
like the house is perfect right because
it'll be fun for you 16 or 2 or 9 weeks
a year but you're also creating
something that's an asset
let me say it one more time in
perpetuity right like once it goes on
there and gets nft it's nft right it is
a contract
like there's the aba team do you know
the story about the aba team from saint
louis
yeah yeah yeah no this sam this is epic
they merged the leagues
the st louis team is out
and the [__] like [__] you we're not
signing the deal and
so what they did was they it was like i
don't know what the finite details were
but they needed them to sign off to make
the merger happen and they tell them
that your franchise doesn't advance
because we're folding some
they they they fight they fight they
fight because they really love
basketball they're like new york like
shemata guys who bought like tv right
at the end they go okay well if that's
the case you have to we have to be
treated financially as the at the time
the 26th or the 22nd or the 24th nba
franchise and in perpetuity we get the
economic split for that so we're out of
the league but economy that we get it
and so as the league
i mean i think they made like a billion
dollars or something it was just youtube
i think two brothers right that's right
that's exactly what's going on it was
two brothers i think they like made like
hundreds of millions hundreds of
millions when that was like a different
number over those 70s 80s and 90s i do
think they got bought out like the
grandkids got bought out by the nba like
in before the last big deal but like wow
unbelievable do you um
go ahead sean i was just going to say
well you were talking about nfd another
i think another nft use case that why i
like when talking about it with you
versus like we've had a bunch of crypto
heads on here you know uh super geniuses
like biology and others and you know one
challenge is
if our audience is a guy who owns his
own marketing agency in st louis he's
sort of like okay
what does this mean yeah like i don't
want the how i want the what what does
this mean what does it mean for me
exactly and to me when i talk about nfts
i think about the fashion industry i
think about why somebody owns a rolex i
think about social media like like
how about this you know how everyone's
like social media is full of [__] like
everyone takes photos and fakes it you
know what's gonna be a much better
social identity what tokens do you have
in your wallet publicly yes
dude i was thinking about this yesterday
read on both of you if i looked at your
time just look at my ear yeah like my
public wallet is going to represent me
because it's not only going to be like
what i believe in crypto punks you know
my v friends collection like but it's
also gonna be like all my jets tickets
right and i'll give you a good one i
haven't mentioned dave matthews publicly
in my entire life but if somebody went
in my if this was going on for 30 years
like like every day on twitter i'd
probably get a gary you went to dave
matthews new year's 99 madison square
garden i'm like oh yeah my friend tokyo
joe love like you know it's a truth
indicator and by the way one last point
this is what really confuses people
every i'm going to give you such a clear
picture that i think will help people
every one of you has an aunt uncle niece
nephew friend grandma when you go into
their house they collect marbles they
collect little miniature elephants they
collect magnets every state they go to
they pick up a match box humans humans
are in hem inherently hoarding assets
and we use them for ourselves because we
like it we get caught up in the
nostalgia and the story and we use it to
flex
flexing a painting or your winnie the
pooh collection that's epic in your
house is kind of hard except for the
people that come through
the blockchain is gonna accelerate
accelerate at a scale right the way i
thought that it would accelerate
communication with social and that's why
i think people are underestimating the
first internet
collected the information
the second internet
created the framework for communication
right this third thing this web 3 nft
thing it's going to
capture the consumerization of assets
and the stakes are [__] high and with
your deal the the new um the the gary
what was it called be friends be friends
you do you um you offer uh a conference
a year are you gonna do that forever or
is there a timeline on that what i
wanted to so my this is pretty
interesting because i've i've done it in
a couple shows but with you guys it's
people like this so i do you want to
host it at michael jordan's house
because we'll let you do it my friend we
can help you host it at michael jordan's
house my guy listen so
for the hardest core
consumers of my content be friends made
so much sense why the amount of times i
referenced walt disney and vince mcmahon
character creation i'm building vaynerx
to buy nostalgic ip i'm going to
refurbish storytelling saturday morning
cartoons all the [__] behind me in my
office right like wrestling and
thundercats and transformers so i'm just
so affected by pop culture and all that
my whole life and like i wanted to buy
like animal crackers from mondelez and i
was going to turn into madagascar like
i've been like in this place forever
right as a matter of fact you know what
b friends is two years ago i was gonna
launch a toy line called
workplace warriors were literal desk
toys right with what basically became
these characters so for me i see nfts i
have my i've been like kind of like
flirting in the winter i have my crazy
eureka like no no this is the [__] it
it right moment i bought eth a long time
ago aaron battalion shout out former cto
of living social got me on in 2015 16.
i've been watching but i wait to the
consumer the normal [__] the marketing
agency st louis moment not the [__]
hardcore infrastructure nerd [__] that's
just not my jam right
so
i go [__] man
i'm gonna build the next pokemon harry
potter transformers but 99.9 percent of
the world's not going to believe me
so
let me launch this program and show
people that you can do a lot more than
just have pictures on it right so to
your point sam like i'm like uh so the
answer is it's a three-year contract the
friends series one says you get a
conference ticket to vcon 2022 2023 2024
right i'll figure [__] out after the
fact but
i knew that that would have such
inherent value that people would lock in
for that but basically what i was trying
to do was trick this is the word i would
use trick my hardest core advocates by
giving them an asset imuv friends the
original thing i just launched as kind
of like the original disney sells you
know those things that sell for like a
drillion that were like they hand drew
snow white in the 40s like if i pull off
what i think i can pull off stuffed
animals toys trading cards movies video
games over the next 40 years this
original nft
has real potential and i wanted to
create
a thing that wouldn't make my biggest
earliest supporters trade it you look at
board ape you look at me base you look
at these epic projects that are killing
right now people are trading i wanted i
wanted people to be locked in
so that by the time the three years are
over they're like wait a minute i'm
never selling this because i wanted them
to benefit the most and the data backs
this up so right now if i go on crypto
slam
uh if you guys don't know there's
cryptoslam.io easy little aggregator of
nft projects i think you guys are like
number eight okay so you're number eight
in the last 24 hours last 24 yeah sorry
it's a 24 hour rolling scoreboard but
you can you you can do up top it's got
all this stuff yeah so we can do like
let's say 30 days all right so 30 days
you're number 12 last 30 days about 12
million of sales volume of transaction
volume and the funny thing is if you go
through all the other ones crypto punks
me bits all these they have somewhere
between thousands or tens of thousands
or you know the top one x infinity is
quarter million buyers that are doing
these numbers doing these transactions
v friends is like an outlier it's like
300 people
with 580 transactions what that tells me
is that there is a small group of
hardcore people who are not looking to
flip this rapidly for a quick buck
because they believe in you they believe
in the utility value of the conference
so i like that because it's different
and you're pushing it at this point i
think i've been very aggressive with
this i'm like do not bet against me i'm
gonna [__] build transformers like
you know like and i think a lot of
people are holding now
be more you know the conference is gonna
be epic and i'm gonna come through but i
think
i think i think they're betting on my
propaganda right now and i'm gonna come
through it's like bitcoin uh the thing
that gets it like early days bitcoin the
people who bought in were because they
were anarchist crypto nerds yes it's
like they needed you need the first
people to buy in for one reason and then
the second people are you know the
speculators you got it and then it's
like once everybody's got the damn
things we all speculated on it now we
can just use it as a medium of exchange
so similarly what's interesting about
nfts
more so than bitcoin today and obviously
things will evolve
it's just functional yeah like v v v con
makes it function like they're about to
get very functional
right like the functionality is going to
be extraordinary
right and so uh so i like v friends i
think v friends is cool i told my guy
before this pod i was like oh i'm gonna
talk to gary today um you know let's
pick up a v friend like go go get me one
off the floor there i appreciate it and
he's like cool the floor price is like
getting a 17 grand now i was like oh
okay well all right all right let's see
i don't like gary that much
i thought i was like i was like i'm
gonna do it but that is not what i
expected i was like that's interesting
that really kind of like opened my eyes
in fact the last few days you've been
seeing so i want to bring back one thing
you talked about which is your wallet is
gonna be a new type of profile it's
going to be a new place to flex it's
going to be a place to learn about
somebody in a real way like like the
only reason i'm in is that right and
then i think youtube is going the other
way you can filter your face you can do
many things to get non-verifiable there
you know it's really interesting the
argument of like us controlling our
narrative because everyone's become the
pr agent of themselves
versus
the black and white public data of what
we buy now don't forget for everyone
who's scared and loves privacy you don't
have to share your
wallet right it's just that my
my argument
is i was there for myspace 2004 when
everyone's like people are gonna get
raped at the mall and kidnapped and you
know i was like nah i think it's gonna
go this way and now it is right
everyone's in i think that's what's
gonna happen with nfts like you've got
the hardcore people that i get on zoom
with like just chopping and they've got
literally like voice d activators and
like screen scenes i don't know who they
are
every
the masses are coming and they're in the
public wallet the rainbow wallet the dot
eth world and i think that's where it's
going you um so you you've been talking
about buying brands and putting them
through vayner for i mean in like year
three four of the company i mean you've
been saying that whole spiel for a long
time i first of all
you haven't done it yet when are you
gonna do it and second of all i think
that this putting him through
the the nft thing is significantly
better than the old model that i bet you
were planning on doing of like well you
know we could put them through the the
vaynermedia machine yep machine you
you've got it like i mean i would much
rather buy an old like a 90s brand and
do this because i'm looking at who the
biggest uh brands are on crypto slate i
mean it's sports sports companies yeah i
mean i think you can do brands they're
going to be better when are you finally
going to execute on that and and pull
the trigger because you've been talking
about it for a long time i'm excited to
see it happen come on jerry
well it's like it's like dude why do you
need
employees still like uh you built that
machine it's badass
do the other thing now yeah you'll
appreciate it i think that's an
incredibly strong observation from the
outside i just know how you know you
know what like it's a version of golden
handcuffs like instead of like selling
your company you have to be stuck or or
like you have a big salary i just know
i'm so [__] close for actually being
a death star versus like yeah it's a
better badass machine than anybody else
has got like i feel that like truly i do
i'm like i got a better machine than the
other [__] 500 people i admire that i
think have this down but it's like but
it's so
it's like so close to being two times
better and four times better and the way
i scratched my itch
was
rezzy the restaurant app which i had a
major exit with empathy wines which like
i was creating and now v friends and
like the v friends thing is really
[__] with me because i'm like
you know oh by the way said you'll
appreciate this i had one executed four
years ago signed and they pulled out
late and kind of had like a clause in
there that allowed them to and i feel
good about this publicly i had animal
crackers bought i mentioned it slightly
quickly when i was talking i had it and
i [__] had the master [__] plan it
was a cook cookie brand i was gonna make
it healthier to be on trend but what i
was really gonna do was turn it into an
animated film and build up like make the
lion like [__] larry the lion like i
was it was kind of v friendly
now
listen ultimately i think i'm going to
play some micro i'm young enough at 45
have the leverage have the
infrastructure that i think i'm going to
do a whole bunch of everything right i
think i can build a studio like pixar
with be friends at the forefront and do
other [__] and i think i can buy
champion when it gets cold again and
refurbished in 13 years because i like
both of those things and i'm going to
try both how much could you have bought
animal crackers for
48 i think the deal was at the time no
[__] yeah what was the revenue
i hate making up [__] i genuinely don't
remember i remember the number pretty
pretty remember around the multiple
it was like nothing it was like
no you're valuing the ip not the core
business of that no they were like just
[__] it was dead they were like
like they didn't give they and like and
we were going to use it as a proxy to
teach them how to do it with their like
it was [__] set up well you did it
with uh
nilla wafers
i mean from a marketing standpoint we
crushed it there and you know i i really
scratched my itch with k swiss
k-swiss was [__] finished dead done
what happened to him something happened
recently yeah right the reason i sold it
to a chinese apparel company
k-swiss was at the forefront of that
leverage we [__] exploded not only
did we sell a [__] load of garyvee
sneakers the residual effect on the
brand was very real that was that's the
closest i've come to like testing my
machine only difference was it was a
fake test because i was so involved with
it in the face my plan is not to be that
as a matter of fact the best part of be
friends for me
is gary vee has been the catalyst for
all the [__] i'm passionate about like
work ethic patient
i'm so pumped that i'm gonna be over the
next three years be able to go a little
bit more in the backdrop and let these
and let these characters take over for
me as i build that ip so i'm looking
forward to that well that's what i was
going to ask you when i was watching
this garage sale video i was like
this is great content but man he
actually had to go to 20 garage sales
and i'm sure there's some fun to it but
also there's you graduated past that
stage in your life and that's the
biggest thing that pisses me off of my
bougie [__] friends like gary the
[__] are you doing i'm like [__] you you
you you go play golf and go on a yacht
i'm in a [__] garage so i'm not
telling you what to do like you know
like even besides that like i know you
know i've done this podcast now for only
i don't know 18 months right so so we're
we're new to the game something like
that
and
there's a lot of benefits of building up
this personal brand it's like boom i
want to raise a fund i raise a fund i
launch a course i sell out you know like
you can make a lot of money when you
build a personal brand you build trust
with an audience
by giving them giving them giving them
like yeah like you say and then you you
sort of have your ass later so the the
part i thought was interesting is man
he's been on this
what you know quote unquote treadmill of
creating content you know you're in your
call you're in your uber going somewhere
you know you gotta for talk you've got a
cameraman with you and you gotta put out
a sound bite for instagram reels cause
that's the new hot [__] or whatever and
so like does are you i guess like this
is more of a personal question like sam
wanted to know that how the hell did you
manage the cash flow question this is
mine as like i see myself doing this
content thing for a long time but i
don't want to work as hard as you as far
as creating that much content do you do
it because like it's fun do you do it
you know are you do you feel like you're
on a treadmill when you're creating this
much content this much garyvee
the answer is i only do what i like as a
matter of fact like i'm not hitting all
my
my team and my quotas right now with my
content these last two weeks because i
can't stop being on crypto slam open c
discord like
you you'd be stunned how how much i
could shut it down or triple down
i understand the benefits of it and the
leverage and i always did i always
thought the community and brand
was very underestimated in the last 10
years i just feel like people are just
getting around to like oh [__] this is
like the actual game
but i don't i don't really i
i enjoy it i really do it and i also did
it a little bit different i
slowly i did it by myself for seven
years but then i really built out an
infrastructure of a team right like to
your point like i'm i'm just living and
everyone's recording and then we're
post-producing at scale
how many uh folks are on the team
right now i think there's 22.
and is um
are you the majority owner of
vaynermedia or vaynerx
yes
so then you're able to kind of um it's
not like a vc thing where you're able to
like use the same resources across all
your [__] you don't have to worry about
you don't have to worry about pleasing
everyone that's right or like your
fiduciary i mean your food your serious
your to yourself
but like yeah exactly so like and so i'm
i'm in heavy control it's a long-term
play
i have no board there's no i'm not
publicly traded to your exact point i
can like it's very much just a very
large family business yeah you don't
have to justify to anyone but you and
your bro and what's cool about that is i
don't have to my bro cause i've been
super rel by him and more importantly
you know
i'm
delivering like you know you know this
right like what's super awesome is like
when you're putting the wins on the
board nobody even gives nobody wants to
touch it then keep going keep going
nobody wants to talk to me you know
did you do you pay yourself from the the
company or do you just take all your
side wins and it reinvests most your
your
what would be your salary or income from
the the brand back into the agency
originally i paid myself very very very
little it just is so much of the
percentage of my time so i've started
paying myself probably over the last
four years
um
but i'm still like wildly
undercompensated in comparison to what i
would feel like the god of merit would
come down and she or he would say
yeah you are like way on because it's
kind of all cycling in the same game to
your point
sure
and do you um like do you look back
because i i think you're excited about
web3 yes and you look back at web too i
know you can quickly tell the story of
missing uber you know your buddies with
the guy you miss uber that's a big one
big one what was uh you tell that story
but also just in general what'd you
learn from the web two wave that you're
like okay web three i'm better prepared
because i've been in a long time i love
you for that question because the only
thing i've been thinking about for the
last nine months is like damn this is
the first time i felt like this since
06. right
the thing i learned there was i was
going to meet a lot of people that were
technically stronger than me
teach me new things have incredibly
fun
young
[__] on fire thinkers
different [__] the world is rescheduling
recalibrating
and that i knew that i understood the
consumer and the humans so well that i
would figure out my path within it
i think like you know the thing i
learned with i've told the uber story at
nausea travis is the only person i thank
in crush it my first book besides my
family we were incredibly close
um
what i learned there was defense always
loses i bought my first like apartment
in manhattan i played so conservative up
until like 35 like i had no money first
of all because i was building a family
business i just didn't have a lot of
liquid i had enough to make the uber
investment i passed twice
and there's two things i learned from it
one
the full story is that when i was asked
to invest in uber garrett and travis
were just the inventors of it and ryan
graves was the ceo was going to run it
and i had just failed in putting up a
wine social network called corked and it
was because it was a distraction to my
core and so i was affected by thinking
that if this is their side hustle it's
not really them
reasonable by the way totally reasonable
and you'll be right nine out of ten
times the second one hurts because
travis came back to me on this there's
this grassy knoll i have no idea where
it is in san francisco like a little
park i drove by it like seven years ago
and got like the worst feelings i'm like
i have to go back here every year once a
year for humbleness
i'll tell you i wanna you i know we're
gonna be wrapping up so let me give you
the real this is something i really hope
helps a lot of people i have completely
gone the other way
let me tell you what i mean by that i am
now completely infatuated with investing
only based on the person i have to hate
that would be the word i use and i don't
like that word i would have to hate the
person's idea
to not go if i think that the jockey is
a gangster and it's worked out for me
there's a company called mcmac where i
just saw rachel had one meeting with her
and i said she's one of us right that's
it she's one of us
and she's pivoted four times
but the company is a monster now and is
well on its way and between the uber
thing and the rachel thing like it's
kind of how i'm navigating web 3 right
now i'm really trying to pay attention
to is this person one of us because i
think there's something about a human's
ability to will their way to the success
even if they have to completely change
the business model halfway through
i love it well we uh you were supposed
to bounce uh three minutes ago we don't
want to go over your time i it sounds
like it looks like you're in the
hamptons and it sounds like someone's
preparing dinner right now is that right
this is that
do you have someone who is vacuuming and
cooking dinner right now we're setting
up infrastructure for the weekend but
listen i i uh let me say this
it's super fun for me to see this show
pop from afar
like they're not you know it's a very
funny time in society where like
work ethic and the grind like i i'm
incredibly
excited that we have a balanced
conversation
but
the energy of entrepreneurship is just
such an important variable and so
i i appreciate what you guys are doing
this space and i'm not gonna i'll have
to ask him if it's if he's cool if i
blow up his spot a little bit but me and
gary had dinner with like eight or ten
other people like two months ago and i
went back to this guy's house uh about a
month ago again for another dinner we're
gonna have to tell the story about this
guy's house it was it was like the
craziest house i've ever been to
and uh pretty we're gonna we're gonna
tell them
listen i'd love to come back if whatever
you guys feel is a appropriate time for
recycling a guest hit me up i wish you
nothing but good and
and thank you for having me on
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back